yeah now I've made any number of
mistakes in my career I think one thing
you don't realize I had success you know
early on and you know I tamed some
rather exalted positions pretty quickly
and in entertainment and I don't know if
it says true in other fields but you
know there's a quantity called heat and
if people think you're the hot thing
then they are very eager to work with
you but he does dissipate in a
dissipates quickly and so I because I
sort of jumped into the game with a
great deal of heat i thought i would
have it eternally and i spent about five
years at a show called news radio and
really burned myself founder do it was
there was no more exhausting show in the
history of television and when I was
done with that I said I'm going to take
a year off from TV i'm going to know i
have some script ideas i want to write
but i'm just going to keep away from
this not which was great psychologically
but i did not realize how quickly josh
lee you know young man on the rise could
be oh yeah that guy so it is i had to
learn to strike while the iron's hot you
know and it's a lot tougher to uh to get
your name out there again once you've
left the heat dissipation